movies are totally wasting POV camps
seeing carnage through a character's
eyes used to mean something three
decades ago sam raimi piloted his camera
in Evil Dead like it was strapped to a
crazed demon the original terminator
showed us a robot's outlook complete
with a barely digital heads-up display
and a bulky come back algorithm but I
mean come on
a sophisticated futuristic AI with
grainy 640 by 480 peepers yeah what did
these have in common they were awesome
and it should have just gotten better
from their head not a video cam imagery
was supposed to bring the action of a
fantastic first-person shooter to
real-life not turn every movie into a
vapid first-person shooter case in point
Riddick the final chapter of Vin
Diesel's space follies trilogy the first
film pitch-black was a perfectly fine
mid budget thriller in which the
protagonists ability to see in the dark
was a vital and hair-raising plot
element but the new one a conventional
blockbuster with token first-person
shots that scream I once played a game
like this I think I can imagine Vin
Diesel's point of view when he agreed to
produce his bombastic blockbuster
if you really want to commit to POV
Hollywood
I demand an entire summer blockbuster
that's filmed from a first-person
perspective you it if you think about it
it actually be less expensive to mount
because all cool heroes turn their back
on explosions and when the hero's evil
half robot father cuts off the hero's
hand he could just black out and then he
asks of psychotic break and he starts
hallucinating giant bats like Hunter s
Thompson who wouldn't go see that let me
know when you figure out how to mount
that Hollywood I'll be over here working
what's your point of view on POV let me
know in the comments and subscribe to
the wired Channel